on va on va complètement changer de
sujet on va parler d'un sujet qui est
cher a dit me mo à m les trottinettes
électriques
ah oui il est des tests eurent temps le
dira tout tout cru il est des tests mais
en tout cas la bonne nouvelle je me sais
que c'est fini pour le flou juridique
autour des trottinettes électriques
puisque quand on dit non nous n'avons
pas être interdite non non on va les
encadrer juridiquement dès la rentrée de
septembre
il ya une nouvelle législation qui va
entrer en vigueur partout en france et
c'est le 13h de france 2 qui nous
explique tout cela
côté législation les trottinettes
électriques sont en roue libre
le ministère des transports veut
encadrer cette pratique et modifier le
code de la route pour les trottinettes
électriques segway ou overboard
désormais vitesse limitée à 25 km heure
interdiction de rouler sur les trottoirs
il faudra emprunter les pistes cyclables
ou les route limitée à 50 km heure
côté équipement casque jusqu'à 12 en
gilet fluorescent pour tous la nuit
avertisseurs et phare obligatoire et
pour conduire il faut avoir 8 ans
minimum
les trottinettes pourront se garer sur
le trottoir uniquement si cela ne gêne
pas la circulation des piétons en cas de
non respect de toutes ces nouvelles
règles de circulation la vente pourra
s'élever de 35 à 1500 euros
le décret pourrait prendre effet dès
septembre prochain alors une amende
entre 35 et 1500 euros
moi ce qui m'étonne même c'est
l'histoire de feu du port de casque qui
est obligatoire jusqu'à 12 ans puis
après douze ans je sais pas pourquoi il
devient plus obligatoire alors que pour
les vélos par exemple il l'est et on
sauverait des vies parce que tu sais si
tu tombes aux avants de même à 25 km
heure en trottinette sur une piste je
pense que ça devrait être ça devient
compliqué il ya quand même eu en 2010 7
285 blessés à trottinette dont les cinq
marins cinq morts + 23 % par rapport à
2016 et 40% des accidents touchent la
tête donc je dis ce que je disais
n'était pas dénué de sens
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
législation justement vous vous n'aimez
pas être hot n' est électrique
là on encadre quand même mais je pense
que c'est une abomination de la société
carrément qui sert simplement beau aux
parisiens pour se déplacer les bobos
parisiens ouvrent à karachi est
électrique du lycée le sait les bobos
les yeux les bobos parisiens qui font la
trottinette électrique qui embête tout
le monde parce que sur le trottoir c'est
très dangereux s'embête les personnes
âgées c'est que moi aussi beaucoup moins
alors je vois beaucoup de lycéens
parce que j'habite à côté d'un lycée je
vois beaucoup de lycéens qui empruntent
c'est trottinette électrique est équipée
pour sa course à l'espace code de la
route qui font n'importe quoi et
maintenant on va les mettre sur la route
avec de vrais dangers parce qu'on rigole
mais on vous l'avait très bien dit pas
de casque donc traumatisme crânien
extrêmement dangereux la même chose
qu'on impose aux vélos pourquoi on
n'impose pas aux trottinette
ils ne font ils font n'importe quoi et
respectent pas le code de la route la
mairie de paris a rien trouvé de mieux
que de mettre des amendes désormais pour
les trottinettes qui serait mal garées
alors faut m'expliquer qu'est ce que
c'est qu'une trottinette mal garées
elles généraient un petit peu pas
beaucoup alors que le principe même de
la trottinette c'était la mobilité pour
tous
oui on a envie de briguer non plus de la
jeter en permier d'impro thouars on
pouvait la pause et contre un mur et
tout ça c'est simplement une idée
supplémentaire de la mairie de paris
pour récupérer de l'argent
un petit coup derrière la nuque d'année
des jo qui avait comblé les 7 milliards
de déficit de la ville de paris on va en
mettre des amendes à tout le monde quand
je vous prenez racketter un petit peu le
bleu le citoyen range évoqué notamment
les lycéens c'est vrai que comme comme
l'accès au permis de conduire est très
cher ils se rabattent les lycéens les
étudiants sur ces trottinette le fait
qu'on encadre et qu'on oui du cerveau
ils sont après la route est devenue et
finalement une sorte de far west on a
des scooters des vélos des vélos et des
trottinettes des monocycles dans des
endroits de plus en plus serré donc
forcément c'est gagnant
non mais attends tendre jimmy dans ce
cas-là interdisons aussi les cyclistes
puisque ces personnes qui sont sur un
deux roues ne savent pas visiblement
rester parce que dit il s'en est servi
énormément ces primes tout le monde en
garde que vous envoient de la route sur
les voitures et les trottoirs pour les
piétons d'accord et on aura beau tir ou
piéton rien d'autre on court on ok
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ml non mais moi j'aime bien le côté un
petit peu monomaniaque de jimmy sur anne
hidalgo parce qu'on est les premiers si
avoir houspillé les trottinettes qui
était sur le trottoir et qui nous gêne
et qu'ils nous saoulent la mairie de
paris dit bon bah très bien on va mettre
des amendes lui dès maintenant vos ce
que ça veut dire que vous on va être
obligé de payer bah oui en fait c'est le
concept c'est si tu n'es pas bien tu as
trottinette d'affaires suit de près avec
quelque chose tu connais car l'amérique
ou l'asie ne suis pas sûr que je te
suivent sur le coup deux années d'al
gore franchement j'en passe et on écoute
gimme more head on et autant des chevaux
et des carrioles il n'y a pas de progrès
donc moi je suis pour la défense de la
trottinette c'est un bon vous allez à
trottinette était un homme
oui et je dormir avec elle je la cage
oserais-je de la câlinerie complet de
nos bases on va s'en sortir il faut
qu'on puisse tous
vivre ensemble rires oui mais ça c'est
on est d'accord que c'est dans un monde
parfait de bisounours caroline vous
savez très bien que dans ce monde là il
ya notamment des couloirs de bus qui
sont heureux réduit maintenant à peau de
chagrin que sur ce couloir on va le
diviser parce qu'on va mettre une piste
cyclable que maintenant sur la piste
cyclable on va mettre des segway et
autres machins à chacun de prendre ses
responsabilités à chacun du constructeur
de la trottinette qui n'a aucune raison
de faire qui ne contenait de 20 à 46
kilomètres heure effectivement ce serait
ce serait absurde jusqu'à la mairie de
paris qui a le droit effectivement de
mettre des contraventions à ceux qui ne
respectent pas une pac aux règles mais
sinon c'est quand même pas très
compliqué de se dire qu'on peut tous
vivre ensemble sous ainsi les miens je
vous vois faire comme moi bien sûr je
suis complètement d'accord avec caroline
je trouve que cette mesure est une très
bonne nouvelle finalement parce qu'avant
les cc trottinette électrique était
détestée de tout le monde les
automobilistes comme jean et mohamed les
piétons les cyclistes alors que là il
existe un cadre on sait que légalement
c'est trottinette pourront circuler sur
la route on pourra pas leur reprocher
après c'est sûr on des insultes par les
siphonner du halal ans qu'on a trois
bobos parisiens
la nouvelle réglementation des
trottinettes on a posé la question est
ce que vous trouvez ça normal au pas
normal normal à 89% on est content
d'avoir réglementer les trottinettes en
tout cas nos téléspectateurs pour 89%
d'entre eux